[موسيقى]
براءه الطفوله ترتسم على ملامح وجهه لكنه
ليس كبقيه الاطفال
عضلات مفتوله بطن مشدوده وبنيه جسديه قويه
عندما كان في عمر العاشره فقط
عشر سنوات ربما يحتاجها بعض الرجال للوصول
الى بنيه عضليه كالتي يتمتع بها هذا الطفل
طفل العضلات الخارقه تعالوا معنا لنتعرف
على قصه جديده من عالم غريب
في ضواحي منطقه
في فيتنام يعيش نينغو
الطفل البالغ من العمر نحو 13 عاما
يتمتع هذا الطفل ببنيه جسديه خارقه تماما
كالتي نشاهدها لدى لاعبي كمال الاجسام لكن
الفرق ما عدا فرق العمر بالطبع انه لم
يبذل اي مجهود للوصول الى تلك البنيه ولم
يتناول ايا من المكملات او الادويه بل هي
حاله طبيه نادره تدعى متلازمه سوبرمان
تتسبب بفرط في نمو العضلات
كغيره من الاطفال يحب اللعب معهم في حي
بلدته الصغيره
ولطالما كان مصدر اعجاب لهم خصوصا وهو
يستعرض عضلاته المفتوله امام ابناء الحيه
وعندما شاركت والدته بعض صوره على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي
اصبح نجما عليها ايضا ما جعل الصحف
العالميه تتهافت لنشر صور واخبار هذا
الطفل الخارق
الاطباء يشخصوا حاله من على انها حاله
وراثيه نادره تسببت له في نمو مفرط في
العضلات اضافه الى الانخفاض في دهون الجسم
بسبب ما يسمى تضخم العضلات المرتبطه
وهي حاله وراثيه نادره تحدث بسبب طفره في
جين ام اس تي ان ويطلقوا على هذه الحاله
متلازمه سوبرمان
الطفل الخارق يحلم بان يصبح لاعبا في كمال
الاجسام وربما سيكون طريقه لتحقيق هذا
الحلم اقصر بكثير من طريق غيره من عشاق
العضلات المفتوله
[موسيقى]
لا يعرفوا حتى الان ما اذا كانت هناك
مضاعفات صحيه خطيره لتلك المتلازمه لكن
والده الطفل قالت ان الاطباء اخبروها ان
حاله طفلها عاديه ولا تشكل خطرا على صحته
ونموه الفارق فقط انه يتفوق على اقرانه في
كتلته العضليه وربما بعض نظرات الغيره من
الاطفال الاخرين من حوله
[موسيقى]